[Musique]
l'hémicycle du palais de la source a
accueilli ce jeudi 19 novembre une
réunion d'information sur le tage
tremplin pour l'activité des jeunes
un dispositif d'être départementale qui
permet d'encourager plus fortement
l'initiative économique des jeunes c'est
un vrai challenge que de les accompagner
parce que surtout en cette période de
crise sanitaire et donc moi je le dis il
qu'il faut venir via nos services nous
avons cette capacité de vous accompagner
avec lou réseau ou un chance semble de
commerce chambre des métiers chambre
d'agriculture et tous les autres
partenaires pour les accompagner la
création d'entreprise parce que créer
une entreprise
c'est une belle aventure ce n'est pas
facile et quand vous avez la capacité de
le faire
le département vous accompagne
l'accompagnement c'est d'aider à la
création d'entreprise d'aider à financer
mais aussi de permettre le suivi pendant
les trois premières années de la
création d'entreprise ce dispositif a
permis depuis sa création en 2016 de
soutenir 1500 réunionnais en difficulté
d'insertion professionnelle et porteurs
de projets dans la création de leur
propre emploi le taz est très important
pour les jeunes donc c'est un énorme
coup de pouce pour lancer son entreprise
voilà c'est une subvention c'est pas un
emprunt c'est pas comme si on faisait un
crédit tout lé monde avait des
mensualités à rembourser ces voix là tu
une subvention
du département qui nous permet ben voilà
d'être serein dans notre activité est de
savoir qu'on n'a pas voilà d'énormes
charges à rembourser tous les morts à
l'issue de la matinée débat le président
du département le directeur de créa sol
ont signé une convention de partenariat
visant à développer le recours au micro
crédit en faveur des créateurs
d'entreprise accompagnés par la
collectivité bien le mercredi au
microcrédit professionnel en fait ça
c'est une
c'est la raison de notre réunion ce
matin et le microcrédit personnel
microcrédit personnel s'adresse aux
personnes qui ont des revenus modestes
qui ont des revenus sociaux et qui va le
financer des projets de vie un projet de
vie c'est quoi c'est une formation
formation qui va les jeux
on le souhaite bien sûr qui va aboutir
sur un emploi ça peut être l'achat d'un
véhicule ou la réparation d'un véhicule
pour aller chercher du boulot ou se
maintenir des hommes d un boulot
existants et le professionnel en fait
c'est le financement de la création de
la reprise le développement le besoin de
trésorerie
du lourd chaque année ce sont donc plus
de 300 jeunes de moins de 30 ans que la
collectivité accompagne les soutenant
hauteur maximale de 8000 euros
[Musique]